one of my favorite quotes or phrases is
by Charles Mingus who's a jazz musician
who said anyone can make the simple
complicated creativity is making the
complicated simple so what we're doing
is trying to make complicated looking
molecules in the most simple way that
you can
okay well this is this is one of my
latest papers I already wanted to very
excited about this this project at the
moment bit of a mouthful actually a
synthesis of natural product like
scaffolds an unprecedented efficiency
via 12 fold branching pathways I'm gonna
try and explain to you what I mean by
that because that's a bit of a mouthful
like I say hopefully hopefully yeah
there's a lot of complexity here but
this is what we're talking about well
the reason first that we did this work
is that over the years the
pharmaceutical industry is is provided
many interesting compounds which
naturally illness and disease
this is a typical compounds an
antihypertensive agent it's a sedative
to you me the key feature of this is is
pretty flat it's not a lot of three
dimensionality in this molecule and a
few studies over the last couple of
years have shown that actually more
three dimensionality in a drug candidate
can lead to more success and of course
receptors that these guys hit they're
all three dimensionally shape you can
think of them like a cave and these guys
on the go in they obviously fit in key
sites certain interactions but if you
can fill in a bit of the space around
maybe you can get better selectivity and
less oxidation and other types of
degradation what you're looking at here
there's a whole range of molecules all
of which are quite interesting looking
three-dimensional shapes you can see
there's definite three dimensionality
here and here and all of these molecules
are made in a single step from this
molecule here this very simple linear
looking molecule is the the precursor to
all those and they all take one step
here we have two ester groups at the end
over here and we've got simple ketone in
the middle and this is just a chain
connecting these two side chains it has
six Quito and deca dying down diaster
or the keto diaster as we like to call
it so this is the magic precursor it's
gonna wrap itself up and make all of
these complex shapes any think look at
the difference between that simple
molecule there and this really
complicated architecture over here
that's just one chemical reaction that's
done that so the analogy is is a piece
of string here is our piece of string
this molecule here now if we can take a
piece of string or a rope and we can tie
this up into a knot big fingers are
great for glassware you never drop
anything
not so good for little intricate things
like that so there you see we've made a
three-dimensional shape from a linear
shape if you take a much bigger bit of
string and you can get a more intricate
looking knot and that's what we're doing
with this molecule here so what we do is
we take this central functionality the
ketone in the middle and we can convert
that into a whole range of different
species so in this case I'm just going
to take that off there goes the oxygen
we do a condensation reaction with a
hydroxyl amine as an amine an oxygen and
what this can do is this can now react
with one of these alkenes and that forms
a ring then this oxygen here and this
carbon this functionality now is
something we call a nitrone that's now
going to react like so and it just ties
around and then we've just made one of
these molecules here so we've just made
that molecule there from that linear
molecule and that's what we've done we
found 12 different so-called tandem
reactions so this tying up in a knot is
something called a tandem reaction it's
where you make more than one bond in the
same time in fact in this case we're
making this bond here this bonds here
this bond here and this bond here so
we've made all those bonds four bonds
one chemical reaction that's just tied
the whole molecule up what we've done
here is we've created a very simple way
of making a whole variety of different
3-dimensional molecules they look very
different even though they come from the
same precursor and traditionally it may
have taken 10 15 20 steps to make
something like this which in terms of me
in the lab that could be 3 or 4 weeks if
everything went to plan now all of these
were produced in an average of just 1.25
steps per molecule per compound per
architecture or scaffold is the
pharmaceutical industry would call them
but how has what you've made how is the
the things you've made how these useful
though what used to lay to the world
you've made you make them efficiently
that's a great question and so then the
newest way of doing pharmaceutical
research trying to figure out where we
can get our new generation of active
compounds it's called something called
fragment based drug discovery
so in this that we get the receptor
which is part of an enzyme and using
x-ray crystallography we can get a good
map of the cave if you like of the
receptor site and we can do virtual
docking with computers we generate the
shapes of these in the computers and the
computer can dock it in see if it fits
and see if any interactions come off
these key functionalities and also with
this type of screening we can if we can
forget an enzyme which we can get an
x-ray structure of then we can flood it
with a whole variety of these molecules
and actually get an x-ray of these
inside and what the pharmaceutical
industry needs is smallish molecules of
defined three-dimensional shape with
things like these purple groups here
which I've just put on because you can
change these groups into huge loads of
other different types of groups so these
are really useful function or handle
and the majority of them I have to say
came out as we hoped and it was great
the occasional one like this one for
example chemistry just came along and
surprised us a little bit we thought
that this would Bend around and actually
attach over here as well and it turned
out it didn't want to do that so you
occasionally get surprises which are
great huge scientific breakthroughs have
been made through complete serendipity
or surprise or luck and we always want
to encourage luck whenever we can find
it others like this one here
we've designed completely the tandem
reaction we were really pleased when it
came out and it worked and we made this
so this molecule here is this sample
over here now we've got not got very
much in in this sample we've taken a lot
of these and sent away to biologists but
it's a very point one of a gram in here
so this is the this is this one here
this one's a slightly lighter color and
again it depends on what we do with
these are over here not complicated at
all it's all about imagination and it's
all about creativity